jean luc lemoine à ces questions en cas
de pierre hamel et alors là plein en
compte la plus marquante de toute votre
carrière il paraît que c'est charles
aznavour ah bah oui
ah c'est vrai c'était un bon mois moi
c'est un monsieur que j'écoutais de
faire depuis tout petit je les mets j'ai
vraiment écouté que charles aznavour
pendant des années et pour moi d'avoir
rencontré avoir travaillé avec lui j'ai
passé c'est comme un miracle qu'on avait
pas de faire un petit comme ty
charlesbourg a cappella comme ça
ouais attends je vais prendre mieux que
personne enfin qui est moins connu que
les autres comme ça ça oui découvrir en
même temps prenez une collègue j'ai ma
direction j'ai pété les plombs
savourez ces deux pigeons s'aimaient
d'amour tendre
mais l'un d'eux a quitté leurs toits
qu'ils sont non les jours de la tente
les langues sont les nuits saint thois
un pigeon regretter son frère moi je
regrette mon bel amour comme lui dit
j'attends un bruit d'elle le doux bruit
des deux de sombres tous abel band ne
connaissait pas la télé c'est pas ça l'a
fait depuis jo c'est dingue je savais
pas il a fait une chaussure de pigeons
savait pas qu'il a fait une chanson sur
thierry moreau jean monnet saint papoul
franchement décevant vous avez fait
plein d'émissions prob au sérieux parce
que vous êtes une très bonne cliente les
gens quand on dit on à amel bent en
invité on se dit toujours on va rigoler
pas s'aggraver ont des anecdotes alain
al'inverse quand je quand je fais pas
une émission de télé ya plein de gens
qui m'appellent qui dit ce qu'est ce
qu'il y à t tricard ah ouais c'est
pourquoi était pas pourquoi t'es pas
dans l'émission je fais tellement
d'émissions télé que quand je suis pas
sûr une émission tournée les entreprises
avaient même dit m pas sur cette chaîne
n'était pas le temps elle m'a dit ça
normalement quand il ya six mois dit
elle
d'ailleurs je suis maître m'a dit elle
va tenir avec camille combal partenaires
s'est blessé qu'est ce qui s'est passé
et enfin je suis blessé où ça je sais
pas encore
c'est vu regardez la tête de tapha on
dirait didier bourdon le sketch n'est
pas du tout bonato c'est quoi cette tête
chabal y aller julie mais elle suce pas
des chanteurs c'est encore papa ouais
elle juge les la danse d'accord maurane
a les joues chaunois star minerais et
maurane c'est encore la jouabilité parce
que yahia il ya trente ans de carrière
moi j'ai l'impression que j'ai commencé
hier donc c'est ça serait bizarre pour
moi de nous retrouver face à des
artistes à qui j'ai envie de dire
accroche toi courage plutôt que leur
dire bah écoute ça va pas le faire c'est
qu'on m'a donnée de carrière autant ça
fera dix ans à l'épreuve en dix ans de
carrière avec des morts
ça m'a fait bizarre nous rajeunit pas
tout seul
[Musique]